making changes to access policies is
nerve-wracking
how can you be sure that the change that
you're pushing won't break production
risking disruption to your application
is a valid concern and causes many to
delay or even abandon plans to tighten
permissions in their environments
but actively scoping appropriate
permissions and enforcing the principle
of lease privilege is a huge part of
maintaining security for your cloud
deployment
after all allowing access permissions to
remain causes a risk of its own
this very common challenge is exactly
what the policy simulator tool was built
to address
policy simulator helps you determine
what impact a policy change might have
for your users so it doesn't disrupt
developer productivity or break an
application
it goes beyond a static analysis or
comparison permissions
instead it collects and analyzes the
90-day access log history of your
project folder or org to see if your
proposed policy changes would actually
affect your users
let's head into the console to see how
policy simulator works
let's say you have a specific user with
several admin roles and you would like
to change their access to better align
with their essential needs from the iam
and admin console you can use the edit
permissions pane to update the user's
roles and then directly from there
access policy simulator instead of
making the permission changes by
clicking save you can initiate policy
simulator by clicking test changes
policy simulator will then take your
proposed changes and run them through
several steps
first it retrieves the access logs from
a project from the last 90 days
then it replays the access attempts
using the current policy where the user
has the project owner role
next it replays the access attempts
again using the proposed permissions
policy where the user doesn't have the
project owner role but rather the
bigquery admin role
finally it compares the results from the
two replays and reports the differences
between them
these differences are presented as
access changes which are access attempts
that would have different outcomes under
the proposed new policy versus the
current policy
this proposed policy change has several
access revoked changes being reported
which means that the user had access
under the current policy but will no
longer have access when you implement
the change
after reviewing the access changes you
can choose to apply the new policy
directly within policy simulator tool
while our example shows policy changes
for one user this tool is especially
useful when you're making bulk changes
to policies across many users in your
organization which you can do with the
api or cli
it automates what could be a very
cumbersome analysis to summarize policy
simulator is an intelligent tool that
helps you understand the impact of your
policy changes before you make them
through analyzing actual historical
activity data to learn more about policy
simulator and the other tools are part
of policy intelligence toolbox check out
cloud.google.com
policy intelligence and stay tuned as we
dive into more tools in the series
thanks for joining